what's up ladies and gentlemen today is
the day that we have all been waiting
for the first official game of thrones
season 7 trailer has dropped this is
very exciting and I don't want to waste
any time so let's get right into the
breakdown please comment below if you
have anything to add or if I may have
missed something let me know but the
trailer opens up with Cersei explaining
that she has enemies all around her in
the north in the East in the West and in
the South as she is walking into what I
believe could be Casterly Rock but I'll
talk more about this later
the next image we see is gray warming
the unsullied standing in formation
preparing to battle this could also be
at Casterly Rock as well or this could
also be during the field of fire 2.0
which was something I reported on
several times we're going to see more
scenes from this later but during the
middle of next season we will get a
battle between the Dothraki the
unsullied the Lannisters and the tarly's
all in the open field and at some point
Daenerys is going to show up on her
dragons and wreak Shaw next we see the
large table map on Dragonstone the same
table match Stannis Baratheon once used
which will now be used and occupied by
Daenerys Targaryen next we see a ship at
sail during the night this will be the
attack on Daenerys this forces I believe
I think this is going to be when you're
on Greyjoy will strike most likely in
the very first episode I think that
season is going to start off with a bang
ladies and gentlemen so make sure you
buckle your seat belts we know that
Theon in your attack off with some of
his best ships and they met up with
Daenerys instead of him so they're going
to have to pay the iron price
Joran is coming and he doesn't just
bring the storm he is the storm then we
go back to the table map that Cersei
continues her speech about the enemies
that are all around her but then we see
someone sharpening their blade and I'm
not quite sure who this is it does
appear to be a man's hands but I may be
wrong about that the next scene is one
we've all been waiting for and I must
say this is a beautifully shot team but
it is very creepy it almost gives me
like a Sleepy Hollow type of vibe as
Arya travels north all alone in the
woods now we all know Arya is a badass
but this scene felt extra creepy as if
something bad is about to happen but
we'll see more from this later next we
see Jaime and Cersei standing on a
beautifully painted map
most likely planning their next move and
I feel like this could be a casually
rock but there is a ladder sitting right
there which makes me think they could
have just renovated the red teeth but we
will touch more on this part later too
we then see Cersei as she is ending her
speech that she has been saying
throughout the entire trailer thus far
she says they will defeat them Cersei is
very confident although she does not
have the strongest army nor does she
have many allies at this point things
are going to be very interesting next
season next we get a glimpse of the
Lannister army marching in formation and
I have to admit they do look badass with
those new shields they are definitely
ready for war you can see the grass
under their feet which leads me to
believe that this is going to be during
the battle against the three key in the
unsullied as they are marching back from
Highgarden
at some point next season Jaime is going
to take the Lannister army south to
conquer Highgarden after he is
successful and begins to march back this
is when he's going to be ambushed by the
Dothraki and the unsullied in eventually
Danny's dragons
this episode is about to be off the
chains ladies and gentlemen we are going
to see the Dothraki fight in the open
field for the first time and I cannot
wait the next scene is the one we've
seen from the previously released photos
from HBO and I told you in that
breakdown that this is going to be when
Jaime and Cersei meet with Joran Greyjoy
and if you look through the pyre you can
see the man they're talking to is
dressed in all black with short hair
which is the new look you're on Greyjoy
is going to have next season so I
definitely think this is then meaning
with Joran to forge a new alliance and
this is going to be kind of crazy Cersei
and you're on the same team I can't wait
to see what they're going to have up
their sleeve and just like I said in the
photo breakdown Jaime is not happy to
see your own we know Jaime hates the
Greyjoy so he's not going to be totally
on board with making them as an alliance
but Cersei doesn't have much of a choice
right now so she wants to put up a fight
she's going to have to and I think this
alliance is going to further split Jaime
and Cersei relationship without a doubt
next we see Daenerys and company
arriving at Dragonstone and it looks
glorious we did get a glimpse of this
scene recently when HBO released their
previous photos I said in the breakdown
that this was them looking up at the
castle so it appears that's exactly what
was taking place in that photo as
suspected Daenerys Stormborn has
made at home she even puts her hand down
into the sand when she arrives at the
beach this is going to be a very cool
scene next season
we even see Daenerys sitting on her
throne as someone sawed lead into the
room I think I know what's going on here
in this scene which I will explain them
a little bit
we then see the unsullied storming the
castle at Casterly Rock Daenerys is not
[ __ ] around and it's going to be a
bloodbath between the unsullied and
Lannister army next season they will be
engaging each other in multiple attacks
throughout the season but then we
finally go to Winterfell where Jon is in
the council what songs in Brienne but
Jon turns around abruptly I think
someone just walked into the room that
demands everyone's attention this could
be him just getting the news that
Daenerys and her dragons are in Westeros
and they mean business or this could be
a number of people showing up it could
be the Elm could be bran or Oriya it's
really hard to say who for sure but I
don't think we're going to get that big
stark reunion just yet next is it scene
with Littlefinger and Psalms oh and he
is doing exactly what most of us knew he
would do he's back in her ear trying to
further his manipulation he tells her
that her father and brothers are gone
but he or she stands he's going to
remind her that she should rule the
north Littlefinger is going to cause
some serious problems next season in the
north and I think he's going to try to
overthrow Jon but then we see the gate
opening at the wall and I think this
could be one or two things taking place
this could be brand entering at Castle
black or this could be Jon and Company
heading north of the wall - do you know
what we're going to see more from this
later
here we see Theon with hot embers flying
around in the air if you remember from
the beginning of this trailer we see a
ship sailing at night this will be when
you're on a tacks parted Maris's flee
this is Theon most likely freezing up
during the battle because we all know he
is still a broken man he is probably
shell-shocked as he is witnessing Euron
and his men savagely work apart their
Greyjoy fleet this naval attack is going
to be outstanding in this next scene is
a pretty damn important one we see
Melisandre standing on top of the hill
overlooking Dragonstone Melisandre
actually did go south and she is now on
Dragonstone as the marason company are
walking up I think mellow stones are
being with Daenerys could get very
interesting next season especially when
Jon shows up to meet with Danny I'm
wondering if Melisandre is going to
start telling Daenerys that she's the
one I can't wait to see how this plays
out
and I think this next scene is going to
be one of the most intense and
action-packed scenes that we see next
season if you are one of my subscribers
then you know exactly what's going on
right here this is going to be John and
several other key characters going north
of the wall this is going to be when
they get ambushed by the night king and
his army this is going to be absolutely
insane and I cannot wait for this to go
down if all the reports are true and
this scene goes down the way as stated
it's going to knock your socks off
we then see Arya once again as she sets
up camp as she heads north I don't know
why but this scene feels very creepy to
me and I'm concerned for Arya right here
I feel like something or someone is
going to jump out at her I hope this is
when she sees Nymeria once again she
could also went into the Hound of the
Brotherhood here I think something is
definitely going to take place in this
scene I don't think they're just showing
us Arya building a campfire here I think
we're going to get some type of reunion
right here whether it's good or bad
that's still to be determined and if you
notice when she exhales right here you
can really see her breath and I know
that winter is here but I hope to god
there aren't any White Walkers around
Arya could be in some serious trouble
all alone now here is the money shot my
friends this is John and his team
surrounded on a frozen lake by hundreds
if not thousands of Lights this is going
to be absolutely insane and I know that
some of you don't want to see this scene
but it's happening folks I'm sorry but
personally I cannot wait to see how this
plays out next we see Littlefinger on
some creepy shade and I don't really
know what's going on here but I don't
like the look in his eyes this could be
Littlefinger down in the crypts with Jon
maybe he said something to Jon about his
mother or father which causes Jon to
choke him which we're going to see later
in the trailer Littlefinger might say
Ned is not his father which would piss
John off considering he wouldn't know
what the hell he's talking about
we then see the Dothraki going apeshit
as they are charging into battle this is
going to be when the Dothraki attack the
Lannister forces in the open field and
we all know what they say about the
Dothraki fighting in the open field
there are absolute savages then we get
another glimpse of what I think is the
naval attack between Euron and a portion
of Danny's fleet this is what fiown was
watching earlier in the trailer
Geron is going to rip them apart and
then take some hostages and as all this
is going on we can hear Davos giving his
own speech he is saying it doesn't
matter what skeleton sits on the iron
farm I think this is going to be Davos
talk
to the barriers if you remember earlier
in the trailer when we see Daenerys on
her throne and the unsullied walk in I
think this is probably when Davos and
John come in and Davos is going to be
the one doing his talk not to
negotiating with Daenerys and Tyrion
most likely I think Davos is going to
need to help John convince Danny that
the Iron Throne isn't what's important
the war up north against the knight King
is what's important and I hope Davos
speech works because we all know John
could used to help and I think I could
speak for all of us when I say we can't
wait to see the Dragons verse tonight
King and his army that's what we've all
been waiting for and next you see the
mountain confronting someone and it
looked like they had long hair like a
woman's this could be the mountain
confronting one of the prisoners maybe
Yara
or maybe Ilario whatever it is it's not
going to be good in this next clip is
one of my favorite clips from this
trailer
it shows the king in the north grabbing
that little slimy prick Petyr Baelish by
his throat and I can't wait to see this
happen and honestly I hope we're all
wrong and I hope we get to see John be
the person that kills Littlefinger I
think that would be fantastic and
Littlefinger must have said something
pretty offensive to get John to react
like this for some reason I think it
could be a smartass remark about his
parents if it's not that then it's most
likely has to do with Shawn's possibly
because he dropped her off at the
Bolton's in the first place whatever it
is it's going to be fantastic to see
John grab this prick by his throat but
then we get another clip of the
unsullied and Lannister armies fighting
in Casterly Rock and it looks like the
unsullied is ripping them right apart
then we get another scene of Arya and it
looks like she's putting our ear to the
ground right here which I can't figure
out why but it also looks like she is
looking under a door or maybe she's
looking under a bed or something like
that maybe this is her looking for
Edmure down in the cells at the twins
because the very next scene we see an
arm reaching out of a cell door this
might be at mere Tolley
I said in previous videos that I think
Arya will free him after she finished
killing everyone at the phrase but this
could also be septa unella we know
Cersei had her tied down to a table and
she told her she wouldn't die for a very
long time then she sent the mountain
into the ring she might still be alive
but obviously not in very good shape and
I also said in my previous videos that I
do think we're going to see septa unella
again but it could just be a disgusting
mess that we end up seeing I think this
hand is either hers or
in yours next we get another good shot
of John and torment most likely north of
the wall I think this has to be them
running from the night king's army
probably right before they get
surrounded on that frozen lake this is
going to be so intense I can't wait to
see this scene play out I'm really
looking forward to next season with less
episodes it's going to be the most
action-packed season we've ever seen I
hope you all are as ready as I am but
next we see missandei and grey worm and
the clothes are coming off ladies and
gentlemen holy [ __ ] maybe grey worm
didn't lose his pillar this could get
fun but the next shot is even funner we
see Yara and ilaria about to get it on
and I think they better move quickly
because you're on it's coming my ladies
now we know for a fact that the sand
snakes and Greyjoy's are together this
is probably at sea right before you're
on strikes and I wouldn't be surprised
if your arms attack interrupts this
lovemaking session and we also see a
body fall in the water with fire
shooting out above I think this could be
beyond making his escape during the
battle and gets your on and one of the
very first episodes if you've been
following my channel then you know
exactly what I'm talking about
and last but not least we end with the
money shot of all money shots
the Dothraki charging full steam ahead
in the open field with a dragon flying
above pardon my language but the
Lannister army is [ __ ]
we just got a new photo the other day of
day neons rogue on during the field of
fire and this is where that battle is
going to be taken place
the Dothraki unsullied and Danny's
Dragons verse the Lannisters in the
tarly's it's about to go down as the
trailer fades to black we get one last
line of dialogue from a man Jon Snow and
he says the Great War is here I think
this will probably be at the end of the
season when he knows that 19 is or has
already breached a wall that's when the
Great War will have officially begun
there will be nothing stopping them then
comment below and tell me how excited
this trailer major for season 7 I know
my height level went right through the
roof now this was a fantastic trailer it
seems to confirm a lot of things that
some of us already believe and it also
showed a few things that I wasn't
expecting and can't wait to see more of
also let me know if there was anything
on myths that you want to point out to
me I'd love to hear from all of you
thanks for watching my first breakdown
of an
official trailer ever this was so much
fun thanks for watching thanks for the
support and a big thank you to my
patreon supporters I love you all I'll
see you down below bye